distance learning and the lack of  in-person instruction been such a  challenge for so many kids the city of  north las vegas wanted to launch a  program to help out back in august  the southern nevada urban micro academy  provides education support  to children during the fall semester  recreation centers and gyms in north las  vegas were actually transformed into  in-person learning centers to help  students officials highlighted some of  the achievements during the first  semester  they said all the students in fifth and  sixth grade  started the semester below grade level  and now students are making significant  growth  officials say the micro schooling  experience is tailored  to specific educational needs the  academy is preparing for new enrollment  in the second semester  and you can find more information on the  city of north las vegas's website  and the good work they're doing with  those kids